who are your friends you got any good
famous friends I have no friends man are
you seriously I don't know are you a
loner it's a lonely time no come on Adam
Levine is a good friend Adam Levine yeah
do you believe he got married absolutely
I never thought it would happen with him
man so he gives me Faith and I I they're
really happy again I never thought it
would happen with him either I know is
it a whole different vibe when you hang
with him now no they're both so fun I
mean like you know you think about Adam
a certain way but Adam is like uh he's
like a real he's a real gentleman and
he's he's a good guy yeah and and that's
not that's not the thing I mean we just
we have fun I went to elementary school
with him oh yeah everyone went to school
with him I know you know what I mean
were you a popular kid in school no is
that true no I mean you're a good
looking dude at what age do you realize
you got a power off you've spent time
with me but not enough to realize how
annoying I am when Adam says Adam told
me he was not a good looking guy in high
school and that he had acne he's lying
right I knew he was bullshitting listen
no no acne he had a pimple yeah yeah
exactly yeah
he's like oh my God no yeah yeah I mean
no in high school Adam you know he was
in a band he was in the band already in
high school right the name of their band
was Cars flowers and they would play at
the Roxy and stuff that's what I mean
yeah and I imagine the combination of
his looks with the guitar
I mean right it was Lethal he also has
an incredible voice I know yeah yeah so
he was the guy yeah so like when you
went to school he was the guy this is
why he wasn't popular right his friend
was Adam Levine you hung around with the
wrong people around with my friends
laughs